مشاهد للخرابي والدمار تحركات لرجال
الانقاذ وقصص انسانيه مؤلمه للناجين هذه
هي حصيله الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
وندخل الان في الساعات الاولى من اليوم
السادس لهذا الزلزال اكثر من ساعات طويله
مضت يتلاشى بعدها الامل شيئا فشيئا في
الوصول الى نجينا حتى اللحظه خاصه في ظرف
البرد القارس الشديد عدد القتلى ارتفع الى
نحو 25 الف شخص في كل من تركيا وسوريا
تركيا حسب وزير الصحه التركيه يتجاوز عدد
القتلى فيها 20,000 قتيل واكثر من 80 الف
مصاب سوريا اعلن المرصد السوري ان حصيله
القتلى وصلت الى
4500 وهي مرشحه للوصول الى 6000 في مناطق
اعلنت انها منكوبه وهي حلب ولاذقيه وحمى
واد حجمه الكارثه فيها يفوق قدره الجميع
حسب تعبير منظمه الصحه العالميه
[موسيقى]
قصص انسانيه تحمل عنوان المعجزات مكث تحت
الانقاذ اكثر من اربعه ايام ونصف لكنه خرج
على قيد الحياه بعدما تم انقاذه هذه هي
الصور المؤثره للحظه اخراج طفل وهو حي
يرزق في جبله بمحافظه اللاذقيه في سوريا
[موسيقى]
عبودي يا الله
مشاهد مؤلمه بالطبع ولكن هو هذا هو المتاح
في كارثه انسانيه من هذا النوع في جبله
ايضا تمكن الطرق الانقاذ المدنيه في
اللاذقيه من انقاذ ام واولادها ثلاث من
تحت مبنى منهار
[تصفيق]
العثور على احد الاشخاص وهو على قيد
الحياه الف الحمد لله
الف الحمد لله
[تصفيق]
ونبقى مع هذه القصص الانسانيه للناجين بعد
108 ساعات تحت الانقاض تمكن رجال الانقاذ
الاتراك من انقاذ رجل في ولايه
[موسيقى]
ونبقى فيها طي التي تتواصل فيها جهود
الانقاذ ونبقى مع موفد العربيه عمار
الهندي مرحبا بك عمار دخلنا الى ساعات
الليل وربما الى اليوم السادس من هذه
الماساه والكارثه الانسانيه كيف تبدو
الصوره لديك فيها
نحن على وشك ان ينتهي اليوم الخامس رشا
واعمال الانقاذ والبحث عن الناجين
والعالقين تحت الانقاض مستمره والدمار
هائل وكميات الدمار لا تزال هائله جدا
والفرق تعمل على مدار الساعه انا في حي
منكوب وساجول في الكاميرا معك لاشرح لك
اكثر من خلال الصوره ربما تكون اوضح لكم
وللمشاهدين حتى تفهمي ما الذي يحدث هنا
جهود تبذل بطريقه كبيره جدا وعظيمه جدا
على سبيل المثال عمال الانقاذ هنا رجال
الانقاذ هنا يعني يقاتلون من اجل حفر خندق
للدخول الى هذه البنايه المدمره التي لا
تزال الاسر محتجزه فيها ساقترب انا
والزميل المصور بالكاميرا اكثر نحو هذه
البنايه ان تشاهدوا يعني تبدو كيف الصوره
تحديدا
نعم هذه الجهود رشا مضنيه جدا متعبه جدا
وبالتالي المتعب اكثر هو احساس رجال
الانقاذ
الحزن الشديد لدى الاسر واسر الضحايا التي
تجلس في هذا المكان وستشاهدينها الان بعد
ان اتحرك يعني هم يناموا ويستيقظوا منذ
ايام هنا يشعلين النار ويفترشون الارض
وليس لديهم سوى مطلب واحد هو العثور على
الاشخاص او اقربائهم تحت الانقاض هذه
العمليات رجا مستمره في اكثر من مكان يعني
هذا لهذه الصوره نموذج هي تلخص
عمار في طبيعه الاليات والمعدات التي يتم
استخدامها
الاليات الثقيله تتوقف عن العمل حينما
يقتربوا مثلا من صوت او يشعروا بوجود
اشخاص ربما حتى ولو كانوا ولو تاكدوا انهم
اموات يتوقفوا عن العمل لاخراج الجثث جثث
سليمه كما هي وبعد ذلك يتم يتم استخدام
الاليات الثقيله لتفتت الكتل الخرسانيه
الكبيره ويستانف العمل من جديد هذا المشهد
رشا ليس حكرا على هاتاي على العموم يعني
ولا على هذه البنايه الان ستشاهدي بنايات
اخرى ايضا مدمره ولكن هذه حاجيات العائلات
التي يعني تخرج تباعا وبالتالي الاسر
تستدل على اقتراب عمال الانقاذ رجال
الانقاذ من ذويهم من خلال الاغراض يعني
يميزونها فيستدلوا على اقتراب رجال
الانقاذ من اسرهم او عائلاتهم او
المفقودين هذه الصور هذه النيران تشتعل
هذه الاسر تبقى هنا ج لا تذهب الى اي مكان
الى حين اخراج من لديه نيران للتدفئه طبعا
باعتبار ان الجو بارد جدا الكل تاكيد هذه
هذه النيران وهذه البطانيات هؤلاء اناس
نائمون هنا بالشارع رشا ان كنت تشاهدي
يعني هم ينامون هنا يشعرون النيران ياكلون
وينامون هنا ولن يذهبوا الى اي مكان الا
بعد ان اخراج
امن لديهم من تحت الانقاذ هذا المشهد في
تلك البنايه يتكرر ايضا في هذه البنايه
على يمين الشاشه التي يسلط
زميل المصور عليها الضوء هنا هذه البنايه
فيها العشرات من العائلات التي لم تخرج
بعد والاسر تنتظر وكل تقريبا نصف ساعه
يطلب من الجميع الصمت لانهم يستمعوا الى
اصوات
اشخاص يعتقد انهم ناجين تحت الالقاب
فتتوقف العمليات بالاليات الثقيله وتبدا
العمليات الدقيقه جدا وكما قلت
هم يستخدمون اجهزه حديثه منذ الامس تدلهم
او ترشدهم على مكان الاحياء من خلال ربما
النبض او حراره الجسد تحت الانقاض
وبالتالي في حال هل هم اسر الضحايا هل
تونه عن ذويهم نعم نعم هذه اسر الضحايا
على يسار الشاشه
وذويهم ومن الامام رجال الانقاذ وتشاركهم
يشاركهم رجال من الجيش يعني الجيش هنا في
هنالك بعض عناصر الجيش اصلا اساسا تشارك
في هذه العمليات لانهم حينما يقتربوا كما
قلت لك من جثه او من شخص على قيد الحياه
تتغير استراتيجيه العمل لديهم وتصبح هادئه
جدا على ايه حال نحن في مجمع سكني كبير
مدمر وبالتالي سانتقل معك ايضا الى موقع
اخر رشا لتشاهد كيف تسير الامور الان
هذه سياره اسعاف وجود سياره الاسعاف في
هذا المكان يدل على احتمال من اثنين اما
ان يكون هنالك ناجن وهذا احتمال كبير جدا
ولديه معلومه بان هنالك ناجن او وجود
اشخاص يعني جثامين يريدون نقلها هذه
تم الاستناد الى اي مؤشرات هل سمعت
اصواتها هل تواصلوا
معهم لديهم الان اجهزه رشا هم لديهم اجهزه
منذ امس يعملون يعني في اليوم الاول
والثاني والثالث كانوا يبحثون بشكل عشوائي
يستدلون بشكل عشوائي على الجثث من خلال
الاستماع صدفه الى شخص ينادي او يستنجد او
يصرخ هذه المره منذ الامس اختلف الامر
الان حينما يعلم ان ان البنايه فيها اناس
ولم يخرجوا بعد تاتي الاجهزه وتتفحص يعني
مثلا اليوم السيده التي خرجت بعد 100 ساعه
من تحت الانقاض كانت في هذه البنايه التي
تشاهدينها الان وهي
وخرجت سليمه وكانت مستيقظه
استخدموا اجهزه
للاستدلال على مكانها الان مثلا هم يحفرون
خندقا الى داخل هذه البنايه
ساقترب ايضا
ساقترب اكثر بالكاميرا لتشاهدي بدقه كيف
تتم الامور وكم هي صعبه
سادخل ساحاول الدخول الى الداخل لنشاهد
الصوره معا هذه البنايه رشا هذه البنايه
فيها عائلات لم تخرج بعد ومن ضمن هذه
العائلات التي انا تحدثت الى ذويهم هنالك
عائله لشاب سوري
لا تزال تحت انقاض هذا المبنى مكونه من
ثمانيه افراد لا يزالون تحت هذا الركام
وايضا وجود سيارات الاسعاف هنا على الشمال
دليل او اشاره كبيره جدا بان هنالك ايضا
ناجين ربما يتم اخراجهم على قيد الحياه من
تحت هذا المبنى هذا هو المشهد في هاتاي
هذا المشهد عن قرب رشا يعني نحن حينما
يتسنى لنا ان نتحرك بالكاميرا تشاهدين
صوره كم هو حمار كبير الحفر ورجال الانقاذ
بالتاكيد واضح ان هناك جهد متواصل عمار
واضح مما يبدو على الشاشه
طبعا عمار حاول الاقتراب اكثر فاكثر من
هذه المواقع وعن قرب للاماكن التي يتم
محاوله البحث فيها عن ناجين او ضحايا لهذا
الزلزال الصوت ربما يتقطع مع الاقتراب
اكثر من هذه المواقع نتيجه صعوبه
الاتصالات في هذه المنطقه ولكن اعتقد ان
عمار عاد الينا من جديد تفضل عمار ربما
تكون سيده على قيد الحياه
هنالك من يخبرني بانها ربما تكون سيده لا
تزال على قيد الحياه ويتم الان يعني
اخراجها ولكن
اخشى انه كما اعتدنا ان وجود البطانيات
يدل على العكس يعني هنا حينما يطلبون
بطانيات تكون هنالك جثث ولكن لا يمكن
الجزم بانها كنا نسمع طوال اليوم بان سيده
ثانيه وهي محاميه حسب ما اخبروني لا تزال
لان مكتبها هنا وتعمل هنا وانها لا تزال
على قيد الحياه وهكذا ارشدتهم الاجهزه
وعلى ما يبدو انهم يعني وصلوا ولكن لا
اجزم ان كانت على قيد الحياه او متوفيه
اتمنى طبعا ان تكون على قيد الحياه ولكن
تخيلي رشا ساعات طويله حتى
منفذ للوصول الى هذه السيده يعني هذا عمل
مضني ومتعب كثيرا
ويحتاج الكثير من الصبر وبالتالي حينما
تاتي الاسر اسر الضحايا وتكون متوتره مثلا
هم اسر الضحايا لا تريد سوى ان تحصل على
ما تريد تحصل على اقاربها التي
تحت الانقاذ ولكن في المقابل رجال الانقاذ
والاسعاف والعمال الذين يعملون على مدار
الساعه حقيقه يبذلون مجهودا عظيما جدا
للوصول الى هذه النقطه
انا
يبدو انهم يحاولون حاول ان تكون الصوره
واضحه نعم واضح انهم يحولون قطع قطع
يحاولون قطع ربما حديد يعيق تقدمهم الى
الداخل الى حيث توجد او تتواجد هذه السيده
هم يعني
طلبوا بطانيات وبالتالي كما قلت لك هنالك
مؤشرات كما كما نتحدث احيانا عن الاليات
الثقيله هنالك من يقول بان استخدام
الاليات الثقيله يعني ان المنزل ليس فيه
احد على قيد الحياه ولكن التجربه اثبتت
العكس انهم احيانا يستخدمون الاليات
الثقيله ويخرج من ذات المنزل اشخاص على
قيد الحياه وبالتالي لا يمكن الجزم ربما
من البرد القارص على فكره نحن كنا التقينا
شاب
شاب كندا خرج من تحت الانقاض بعد 36 ساعه
وكان السؤال الذي وجهناه له كيف تدبرت
امرك بدون طعام وبدون غذاء كمان
التحدي الاكبر كان امامه في البرد وليس في
الطعام ولا في الشراب يعني هو يؤكد بان
اكبر تحدي امام الشخص الذي لا يزال على
قيد الحياه هو
مواجهه البرد هناك انخفاض كبير الان
يطلبون
هم الان يطلبون من الجميع الصمت على ما
يبدو
توفت يعني هنالك انا سالت احد الاشخاص هنا
يقول انها توفت السيده توفت
هكذا يخبرني بانها توفت ربما تاكدوا انها
توفت
اذا رشا هذه المحاولات
المستمره منذ ساعات هذا ما يحدث احيانا
يعني احيانا تكون الاشارات بان الشخص على
قيد الحياه وتصدر منه اشارات وردات فعل
ولكن الوقت المستغرق للوصول اليه يحول دون
الوصول اليه في الوقت المناسب وبالتالي
يفقد الحياه تحدث كثيرا يعني
انا ارى الان رجل الامن يمسك كيس من اكياس
هذه الاكياس السوداء هي اكياس وضع
تستخدم لوضع جثمان هذا الكيس الاسود
وهذه كلها اشارات للاسف بان السيد التي
كانوا يحاولوا اخراجها منذ ساعات طويله
توفت
كما قلت لك رشا التحدي كبير جدا جدا جدا
هذه صور مباشره منها الزميل عمار الهندي
لعمليه انقاذ سيده تقول المؤشرات انها
توفيت
نعم رشا اذا هذا ما يحدث احيانا
بان المؤشرات تكون
مبشره وفعلا
هنالك اشارات من اجهزه
انها ان الشخص لا يزال على قيد الحياه
ولكن تحياتي انت تعرفها للمحاميه التي
كانت تحت الان هي بنت خالي بنت خالك
احنا اساسها
ثلاثه من العائله لا زالوا تحت
النوم طيب السيده التي خرجت على قيد
الحياه اليوم كالشاب العشرينيه كانت
قريبتها او من مكان ولا شخص
عدد الذين تبقوا الان تحت الانستا
كيف تاكدتم انها توفت بعد كل هذا التعب
والعمل لاخراجها حيه كيف نعم قبل الان
شفنا اني متوفيه الان تاكد
البقاء لله
كم تبلغ كم تبلغ هذه الشابه من العمر
العمر
وشقيقتها ايضا متوفيه
الصوت يتقطع بالطبع لنسمع عمار بشكل جيد
وهذا نتيجه انه اقترب من مساحات قريبه
للغايه من عمليات الانقاذ في هذا المبنى
فيها طائي كنا نسمع الضيف الذي معها
الهواء يتحدث عن شقيقتين يعملان او تعملان
محاميتين
وطوفوا في هذا الزلزال وعمليه اخراج جثه
الثانيه تتم الان في حين تم اخراج الجثه
الاولى قبل ساعات من الان
عمار هل تسمعني
نعم رشا اسمعك ان كنت استمعتي لهذا الرجل
المتوفيه ابنه خاله كانت على قيد الحياه
فعلا ولكن حينما وصلوها كانت للاسف قد
فارقت الحياه وهي شابه عمرها 28 عام
محاميه وشقيقتها ايضا محاميه
وتوفت توفت هي الاخرى
ويؤكد بان
عدد كبير بالعشرات لا يزال تحت انقاض هذا
المبنى وبالتالي العمليات هذه
تقريبا اذا يمكن ان تصحح لي 50
شخص ما زالوا تحت هذا المبنى
صحيح هو قال انه هنالك 50 شخص انا التقيت
باحد الاشخاص وهو شاب سوري اسمه حمزه جاء
من اغازي عنتاب لديه ثمانيه اشخاص عائله
واحده في منزل واحد من هذه المنازل
وبالتالي يعني العدد ربما يكون اكبر من
لانه عدد الشقق كبير جدا في هذه البنايه
هنالك تحديات كبيره رشا حينما نتحدث مثلا
عن بنايه سقطت
وسقطت التي من ورائها يصعب الوصول الى
البنايه الاخيره الا بعد ازاله البنايه
التي تكون في الواجهه وهذا عمل مدني هذا
نموذج مثلا هذه البنايه التي بدانا
المباشر من عندها كانت المشكله الحقيقيه
فيها ان البنايه الاولى التي في الواجهه
دمرت فكان من الصعب الوصول الى البنايه
الثانيه الا بعد ازاله البنايه التي في
الواجهه وهذا الذي تسبب واستغرق وقتا
طويلا ولذلك هم الان
يحاولون الوصول من خلال هذا الخندق الى
داخل البنايه التي تشاهدين عبر الكاميرا
ولا هي مكونه من طبقات وبالمناسبه هو هذه
هذه البنايه ايضا الاسر التي فيها لم تخرج
بعد
هذا نموذج يعني هذا نموذج هذا المشهد
يتكرر في اكثر من مكان رشا ليس هنا في
هاتاي وليس في هذا الحي من هاتاي تحديدا
وانما في احياء كثيره نحن وصلنا احياء لا
تزال مدمره بالكامل بدات فيها عمليات
الانقاذ هنالك وفود اجنبيه يعني من من
وفود انقاذ وفرق انقاذ اجنبيه وعربيه جاءت
راينا اليوم وفد روسي راينا وفد هنغاري
راينا وفد من سلطنه عمان ولكن كل هذا
العدد من الناس
انتبه في ناس نايمين امامك على الارض
كل هذا العدد من رجال الانقاذ يبدو انه
غير كافن رشا مقارنه او في موازاه رقعه
الدمار الهائل في تركيا وتحديدا في هاتاي
وهي يعني من اكثر المدن من اكثر الولايات
التركيه التي تضررت من جراء هذا الزلزال
رشا نعم
فعلا هاطاي من المدن الرئيسيه في تركيا
التي تضررت من هذا الزلزال بالاضافه ايضا
الى كهرمان مرعش وهي كانت مركز ايضا لهذا
الزلزال ايضا ديار بكر هناك
وفقا لتوصيف الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان عشر محافظات كامله في تركيا تضررت
من هذا الزلزال شكرا لك عمار على هذه
الجوله وعلى كل هذه المتابعه الحيه
والمباشره
وهذه صور مباشره ايضا تاتينا من ديار بكر
حيث تتواصل عمليات الانقاذ ورجال الانقاذ
كما تشاهدون يواصلون العمل ليلا نهارا
لمحاوله البحث عن ناجين او رفع هذا الدمار
والركام بحثا عن ضحايا لهذه الكارثه
الكبيره التي ضربت جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا
هذه صور تاتينا من ديار بكر ديار بكر من
المدن التركيه ايضا التي تاثرت وبشده منذ
لحظات الاولى لوقوع هذا الزلزال القوي
الذي بلغ درجته 7.8
[موسيقى]
وفي محاولات اطقم للانقاذ البحث عن عجينه
تحت الانقاض برزت عده طرق يستخدمونها اكثر
من غيرها نتعرف على بعضها مع الزميل زيدان
زنكلو من اضنه جنوب تركيا في المواقع
المدمره نتيجه الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
تعتمد فرق الانقاذ على عده طرق للتاكد مما
اذا كان هناك ناجين تحت الانقاض ام لا
اولا الطريقه التقليديه التي يقوم من
خلالها احد رجال الانقاذ باصدار نداءات
متكرره بعد فتح فجوه بين الركام وينتظر
حتى يسمع ردا من الداخل في حال لم يصله رد
تلجا الفرق الى الطريقه الثانيه وهي
الكلاب المدربه التي تستشعر وجود احياء
كذلك تلجا فرق الان الى استخدام كاميرات
المراقبه الحراريه التي تستطيع تحديد
اماكن العالقين تحت الانقاض طبعا نحن نصور
هذا التقرير بعد انتهاء التطبيق هذه الطرق
لان الصمت والهدوء التام شرط الاساسي
لنجاح هذه الطرق زيدان زنجلو اضنه
زيدان زنكلو المراسله العربيه من اضنه كنت
معنا زيدان في هذه الصور لاستعراض هذه
الطرق للانقاذ نهارا ماذا عن الوضع الان
ليلا
نعم اعمال الانقاذ رشا تستمر في اضنه
محاولات حديثه لتسريع العمليات وانهاء
عمليات ازاله الاركان الركام عفوا ورفع
الانقراض في اسرع وقت ممكن حتى تتفرغ هذه
الطواقم الانتقال الى مواقع اخرى في
ولايات اخرى
اكثر فيها دمار اكثر كهاتاي او كهرمان
مرعش مع الاسف في هذا المبنى حتى الان كل
الجهود التي يبذلها رجال الانقاذ وحقيقه
جهود عظيمه وكبيره جدا لم تتكلم بالنجاح
باخراج اي من الاشخاص العالقين ويبدو ان
فرص الوصول في هذا الموقع اتحدث فقط في
هذا الموقع فرص الوصول الى ناجين يبدو
انها بات الضئيله جدا يعني حتى الان عده
جثث اخرجوها منذ وصولنا الى هذا الموقع
وحتى الان بدايه قبل
ثلاث ساعات تقريبا اخرج الجثه في الساعه
الماضيه اخرج جثه لا ادري اذا كان هناك
الان
الان يواصلون العمل كنت
لذلك هناك ايضا جاءت سياره اسعاف اخرى
يعلم يبدو هناك جثه عالقه تحت الانقاض
يحاولون الوصول اليها
يعني حتى الان لا يوجد اخبار مبشره رغم ان
الاعمال تستمر بوتيره عاليه فرق الخبر
فريق من الخبراء يحاول تمشيط الموقع بشكل
كامل للتاكد فيما كان
اذا كان هناك مؤشرات توحي بان اشخاص ما
زالوا على قيد الحياه رغم ما ذكره عمار
حقيقه قبل قليل ان اكبر عدو من خلال هذه
الصور يعني هذه الفرق تعمل في
اضاءه ضعيفه للغايه المولدات تبدو انها
ضعيفه وبالتالي الجهود تواجه تحديات كبيره
على الارض
ليس فقط المولدات نتحدث عن حتى يعني الحجم
الدمار يعني المبنى مكون من اكثر من 10
طوابق وبالتالي مبنى ضخم وهذا وهذا الركام
ليس بمبنى واحد بل اللي مبنيين حسب ما
اخبرنا احد عمال الانقاذ مباني متجاوره
هبطت تباعا طبعا حسب ما اخبرنا ايضا ان
احد الناجين ان احد المباني تهدم بشكل
تقريبا نصف المبنى
تهدم بشكل كامل بعد يومين من عمليات
الانقاذ وانتشال كل ما استطاعوا انقذه
واخرجوا الناجين من هناك وبقيت واخرجوا
جميع الجثث كان هناك
اضطرار او قرار صعب لدى فرق الانقاذ بان
يقوموا بهدم الجزء المتبقي لانهم لا
يستطيعون اكمال عمليه الانقاذ
لا يستطيعون اكمال عمليه الانقاذ وهذا
المبنى المتبقي مهدد بالانهيار اي لحظه
على
فرق الانقاذ لذلك جاء قرار
بهدم الجزء المتبقي نعم نعم نعم لكن حسب
ما اخبرني اقرباء احد الاشخاص الذي كان
يتابع الوضع من هنا ان ان القرار اتخذ
عندما تم التاكد بشكل قطعي بعدما احضروا
فريق الكلاب المدربه والكاميرات الحراريه
وتاكدوا من عدم وجود اي شخص اي نبض او حتى
الكلاب لم تعطي اي اشاره لوجود اي احد على
قيد الحياه واتخذ القرار والهدم لاستكمال
عمليه التنقيط في بقيه الموقع وبالتالي
بشكل اكبر لنجد النطاق الجغرافي بشكل اوسع
التي تعمل فيه فرق الانقاذ الان وهل
المنطقه التي توجد بها انت الان هي
المساحه الجغرافيه الاكبر التي تضررتي
اضنه
في اضنه لا يوجد مساحات يعني الحال في
اضنه مختلف تماما عن ما نقله الزميل عمار
في هاتاي او في كهرمان مرعش لا يوجد احياء
مدمره بالكامل او عشرات المباني التي سقطت
وانهارت في كل منطقه من المناطق في بعض
المناطق يسقط مبنى او اثنان على الاكثر
الشرطه التركيه تضرب طوقا امنيا ويدخل
لرجال الانقاذ الى هذا
المكان ومن ثم يقومون بعمليات الانقاذ
وازاله الاركان كما تشاهدين على الشاشه
وسط عده ابنيه هذا المبنى ومبنى اخر دمر
لكن الابنيه البقي او بقيه الابنيه يعني
او الحمد لله بقيت سالمه فيها تصدعات طبعا
لكن تم اخراج سكانها منها بشكل كامل
وبالتالي الدمار كان يعني محدود في مناطق
معينه لم ياتي الدمار على احياء بالكامل
كما في هاتاي التي كانت نسبه الدمار فيها
مرتفعه وهي اكبر نسبه في تركيا في عموم
اضنه يعني وكما اكد واليظنا ان عدد
المباني المدمره تقريبا
11 بناء تم الانتهاء من موقعين ازاله كافه
الركام ورفع الانقاذ اي ان المواقع
المدمره المتبقيه تسعه يحاولون ازاله
الركام والانقاذ منها قبل ان ينتقلوا الى
مواقع اخرى طبعا المباني المتصدعه هنا في
اضنه المسح الاولي اشار الى 26 بناء متصدع
ما بين
تشققات كبيره كاحد المباني القريبه من هذا
الموقع والتي امرت السلطات فورا بهتمه لكن
بعد انتهاء عمليات رفع الانقاض وما بين
تصدعات وتشققات نوعا ما طفيفه لكن بحاجه
الى تقييم من فريق متخصص للتاكد مما اذا
كانت
في حال عمليه ترميم هل ستكون صالحه طبعا
من المدن
التركيه التي تشتهر بالسياحه فيها مواقع
سياحيه جيده يقصدها السياح هي سادس المدن
التركيه من حيث الاهميه ووفقا لزميل زيدان
الان حجم التضرر في اضنه وفقا للتقديرات
الاوليه كان ضئيل على عكس بعض المدن
الاخرى كهطاء كما شاهدنا او كهرمان مرعش
كنا نتحدث زيدان عن انه قد يتخذ قرار
بانهاء اعمال الانقاذ في اضنه سريعا
للاستفاده من جهود الانقاذ في محافظات
اخرى اكثر تضررا هل بات واضحا الجدول
الزمني الذي يتم فيه التفكير في تحقيق هذا
قطعا موعد نهائي لا يوجد لكن يعني بعض
رجال او فرق الانقاذ وتتوقع بشكل تقريبي
يعني وهو ليس
قرار نهائي ربما تنتهي هذه الاعمال بحلول
يوم الاثنين لكن كما ذكرت
موعد تقريبي او تخمين من فرق الانقاذ التي
تحمل التي تعمل على الارض وليس قرارا
رسميا بانهاء هذه العمليات هم يقولون اننا
نعمل وفق الظروف والتطورات التي تظهر
امامنا والمعطيات التي تظهر بناء عليه
ربما ربما في حال كان هناك امل بوجود
داجين لا شك ان عمليات رفع الانقاذ
ستتواصل لكن كما ذكرت اليوم الخامس يقترب
على نهايته ونحن على وشك الدخول في اليوم
السادس والامل لا شك تتضائل لكن بقعه امل
تاتي من كهرمان مرعش او من هاتايك
مثلا اخراج احد الاشخاص الناجين او العثور
على شخص على قيد الحياه يزي المزيد من
تمسك فرق الانقاذ بالامل ومحاوله بذل
المزيد من الجهود سواء كان هناك او هنا
عندما تاتي الاخبار على كل هذه الجماعه
الولايات المنكوبه نعم في اضنه والتي لم
تتاثر كثيرا اظن تحديدا لها مكانه تاريخيه
وسياحيه كبيره لانها تضم نماذج للعماره
المتميزه للغايه لذلك كانت مقصد دائما
للسائحين زيدان زنكلو مراسل العربيه من
اضنه شكرا لك
هذا واكدت فرق الطوارئ في سوريا ان العديد
من المنازل في مدينه حلب التي تلقت الضربه
الاكثر ايلاما من الزلزال تضررت بشكل كبير
او انهار تماما وحسب الفريق لا يزال
الكثير من السكان عالقين تحت انقاض البيان
البنايات في حلب التي يقيم فيها ملايين
اللاجئين الذين تشردوا بعدما افقدتهم
الحرب الاهليه منازلهم
[موسيقى]
وفي اطار الحديث عن المساعدات الى شمال
السوري منذ قليل تحدثت المندوبه الامريكيه
في الامم المتحده في انه هناك حاجه ماسه
لمزيد من المعابر والطرق لمحاوله الوصول
الى الشمال السوري وقالت ان العقوبات
الامريكيه على سوريا لا تتعلق باي حال من
الاحوال بمساله المساعدات كانت الامم
المتحده اعلنت ايضا انه وصل بالفعل فريق
من
المقيمين للخدمه التي تقدم من مساعدات في
الشمال السوري للتعرف على حجم الاضرار
والحاجه الفعليه
للمساعدات والدعم في حديثها ايضا العربيه
اكدت المتحدثه باسم برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه في الشرق الاوسط ريم ندى الحاجه
الماسه لفتح المعابر السوريه لتسهيل ايصال
المساعدات للمتضررين من الزلزال
هناك مخزون يكفي لمئه الف شخص وجبات
لا تحتاج الى طه تكفي لمده اسبوع وهناك
مخزون يكفي الى يكفي مليون ونصف
ولكنها حصص غذائيه شهريه ولكن تحتاج الى
بالنسبه لدخول المساعدات نحن نستخدم ممر
باب الهوى نحن نستخدم المعابر في داخل
سوريا ولكن بسبب يعني بسبب الزلزال
والدمار الطرقات
مدمره ولذلك هناك بطء لذلك
ندعو الى فتح مزيد من الممرات هذا كان
هناك باب السلام يدخل منه تدخل منه
المساعدات فقط البطء البطء الوصول بسبب
الدمار في المنطقه
ونشير الى اخر بيان صدر عن الدفاع المدني
السوري يقول ان امال تضاؤلت خلال الساعات
الماضيه في الحصول على ناجين حتى اللحظه
ويقول ايضا ان هناك حاله احباط عامه لعدم
وصول معدات متطوره حتى اللحظه
للاسهام في عمليه الانقاذ في الشمال
السوري وخاصه في الشمال الغربي قالت منظمه
الصحه العالميه ان زلزال اعاد الى الواجهه
ما وصفته بالازمه المنسيه في سوريا واكدت
انها مساعده لارسال مساعدات كبيره الى
سوريا لكنها تواجه الكثير من القيود اضافت
الصحه العالميه ان حجم الكارثه في سوريا
كبير للغايه ويفوق قدره المجتمع واشارات
الصحه العالميه الا ان الزلزال الذي دمر
اجزاء كبيره من المدن في سوريا اعاد تسليط
الضوء على سوريا التي تعاني اصلا
هذا وقال المدير الاقليمي لجمعيات الصليب
الاحمر والهلال الاحمر لمنطقه الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا حسام شرقاوي في لقاء
مع العربيه ان الاوضاع في الشمال السوري
صعبه داعيا في الوقت ذاته الى تنحيه
السياسه جانبا والتركيز على ايصال
المساعدات لكل سوريا في مناطق فيها وضع
امني حساس في مناطق وصلتها المعونات وهذا
يدور 24 ساعه
الوضع ماساوي كما كل التقارير تفيد وبدات
تظهر حجم الدمار
نحس الجميع انه نحط السياسه على جنب ونركز
على انقاذ الناس وتقديم المعونه
نصير مره اخرى الى بيان الدفاع المدني
السوريه الذي يقول ان وفقا للمعطيات على
الارض لم يعد هناك عمليات للبحث والانقاب
ولكن نحن الان في مرحله انتشال الضحايا
والجزر هذا وتواصل فرق الانقاذ الدوليه
عملها في المناطق المتضرريه المتضرره في
تركيا وسوريا ومن الفرق المستمره في العمل
على الارض فريق الانقاذ الاردني الذي يضم
99 منقضا متخصصا واطباء من الخدمات الطبيه
الملكيه والذي انضم لفريق انقاذ من عده
دول حول العالم تعمل الان على الارض في
سوريا وتركيا
وفي ادلب ايضا التقطت كاميرا العربيه صورا
تظهر حجم الدمار في ريف ادلب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لا لا
ونبقى معكم في هذه المتابعه الحيه للشمال
السوري وينضم الينا من ريفي ادلب الصحفي
محمد الاشقر مرحبا بك محمد الامم المتحده
اعلنت انه تم وصول وفد من لديها الى سوريا
وانه الان يجري تفقد الاوضاع والحاجات
الانسانيه العاجله هناك ماذا صحت هذه
الانباء على الارض
محمد
نعم بالنسبه لهذا الموضوع في شمال نعم
بالنسبه لهذا الموضوع في مناطق سيطره
المعارضه وتحديدا في شمال غرب سوريا لم
يدخل احد لتقييم الاوضاع الى حد هذه
اللحظه ربما الامم المتحده والمنظمات
الدوليه تقصد بما ببيانها
الشراكات مع المنظمات المحليه المنظمات
الانسانيه المحليه ربما تقصدها بما قالته
ولكن هناك معلومات تشير الى ان بالفعل
وفدا امميا دخل الى مناطق سيطره النظام
لتقييم عمليه توزيع المساعدات التي وصلت
طبعا ان تحدثنا عن المساعدات فنحن نتحدث
عن قافله دخلت
ظهر هذا اليوم من معبر باب الهواء الحدودي
مع تركيا وهذه القافيه لا تتالف من اربعه
عشر
شاحنه محمله بمواد
طوارئ
كالاسفنج والاغطيه والسلل الغذائيه والسلل
المنظفات ايضا
دخلت خمسه شاحنات بشكل منفرد عن طريق احدى
المنظمات
نعم محمد
قالت يوم امس قيل انها لا تندرج ضمن
المساعدات الامميه التي
المخصصه لضحايا الزلزال طبعا مناشدات
كبيره اطلقت من شمال غرب سوريا لتوجه
المساعدات الدوليه والامميه باتجاه
المنطقه الدفاع المدني عمل بكل طاقاته على
مدار الايام الماضيه محاولا انقاذ الضحايا
من تحت الانقاض ولكن بعد اقترابنا من دخول
اليوم السادس لهذه الكارثه صرحت صرح
الدفاع المدني ببيان له على ان امكانيه
محمد
نعم الزميل محمد الاشقر كان يتحدث عن بيان
الدفاع المدني السوري تفضل
نعم
نعم يعني ولكن ان سمحت لي ان انقل احساس
الاهالي في محيط المناطق التي يتم انتشال
الضحايا من تحت
بحذر الجميع يترقب بامل الجميع يترقب
الدموع في عينيها رغم احتماليه
انقاذ اقربائهم الضئيله جدا بعد هذه
الفتره الا انهم ما زالوا يعيشون على هذا
الامل طبعا
تاخر
انقاذ الضحايا او ارتفاع اعداد الوفيات
كان
بسبب عده عوامل لعل ابرزها ان فرق الانقاذ
وفرق الدفاع المدني تعمل بادوات بسيطه
وبعض الاليات
للحفر لا تملك اي ادوات او اي اجهزه او اي
معدات متطوره
بالفعل بيان الدفاع المدني في شمال سوريا
والذي جاء محبطا في هذه اللحظات ولكن محمد
هل من بادره امل لفتح بعض المعابر لتوسيع
الطرق الى معبر باب الهوى باعتباره المنفذ
الرئيسي ماذا عن المعابر الاخرى السلامه
او الراعي هل من اتصالات تتم مع اطراف
سياسيه ما لدعم وصول المساعدات هل اي
انباء عن هذا الامر
على ان دخول القوافل المساعدات الامميه
سيستمر هو معبر باب الهوى حاليا هناك وعود
بافتتاح عده معابر لدخول
الصوت يتقطع لا نسمع محمد بشكل جيد وهذا
امر طبيعي صعوبه الاتصال في الشمال السوري
من ريف ادلب الصحفيه محمد الاشقر شكرا لك
يا محمد على هذه المعلومات
ورغم الجهود الكبيره التي تبذلها فرق
الانقاذ والمتطوعين الا ان تصرفات بسيطه
قد تنقذ حياه شخص وتغير حياه شخص اخر وذلك
بعد ان فات الوقت بشكل كبير وهو ما ادى
الى صعوبات جامه الا ان امل بلقاء يجمع
اسره واحده ظل عالقا في الاذان
هذه الصوره انتشرت وشاهدها وسط مقاطع
المصائب ملايين السوريين رغم الكدمات
والجروح طفل يلتهم وجبته الاولى بعد ايام
من البرد والجوع تحت الركام لقب بطفل
الموزه لكنها لم تكن بالنسبه لابراهيم
مجرد موزه بعد انقاذه من تحت الركام نقل
لمستشفى عفرين حالته كانت حرجه واعتبر
الناجيه الوحيد من عائلته احدهم قرر نشر
الفيديو املا بان يصل قريب له او جار فضل
الولد صدفنا بمشفى عفرين ما كان في لا اب
ولا ام لحاله وحيد اعطيناه اماكن بطريقه
يعني ما بتتخير
فصورناه فيديو نشرناه السوشيال ميديا
وقلنا اذا حدا بيعرفوه ما الى ذلك
ما كان معجزه تحول الى حقيقه اما اللقاء
فقد رافقته دموع الفرح عاد الاب للبكاء
بعد ان جفت عيناه
الاوضاع الانسانيه الصعبه تسيطر على
المشهد بالطبع وضعه صعب تعيشه الاسره
التركيه والعربيه المقيمه في غازي عنتاب
بلا ماوى يبيتون بالسيارات والوسط درجه
حراره تصل الى اثنين تحت الصفر مفرد
العربيه زار احد التجمعات ورصد اوضاعهم
الصعبه
يتواجد اكثر من خمسين شخص يتناوبون على
هذه الامتار طوال اليوم كل اسره لها
ساعتين يقضونها في هذه المنطقه
يتدفؤون بها ويعودون من جديد الى المكان
الذي هم يتواجدون فيه اغلب اليوم وهو
السيارات حيث في هذا الشارع وفي مقابله
مباشره تقع السيارات التي ينامون بها اغلب
هذا اليوم كما هو الحال في هذه
الامام هذا الشارع وايضا في هذه المنطقه
يطبخون
اكلهم والمشروبات الدافئه التي
يتدفؤون بها في هذه
المنطقه بعد ان
ضرب الزلزال منازلهم واصبحوا بلا ماوى
وهذا هو الحال بشكل عام في مدينه غازي بن
غازي عنتاب التي ضربها زلزال وتاثرت
واصبحت اكثر المدن تضررا في بسبب هذا
الزلزال كما تشاهدون في هذه المواقع
يتواجد هؤلاء النازحون
وعددهم كما ذكرت 50 شخصا الا انهم لديهم
ساعتين فقط يستدفعون بها في هذه الخيمه
المعدوده من ثم يعودون الى سياراتهم وايضا
لديهم اطفال كما هو واضح بهذه الصوره
وسنستطلع ايضا الاوضاع مع هذا
من سوريا قلت لي طيب حدثنا اسمك وحدثنا عن
وضعكم هنا كيف كيف هو
انا فادي من حلب مقيم بغازي عنتاب
من يومين ثلاثه الساعه اربعه ونص فجر يعني
نزلنا على الشوارع خفنا متنا مثل الناس
يعني حسينا البيت راح ينزل فونا يعني
خالصين هربنا طلعنا لبرا
وشوفت لحد الان من محل
محلائق يعني نحن ولا اتراك مو بس نحن
الحديقه شي منا هون يعني مساعدات تاخرت
شوي لحتى وصلت
هلا بكره راح عم يصبوا خيم افاد وما افاد
اذا هذا هو الوضع في غازي غازي عنتاب التي
ايضا وضع الخوف بالنسبه لكثير من الاهالي
هو الذي يمنعهم على الرغم من انه الزجاج
لديه او مضى عليه ما يقارب خمسه ايام الا
انهم الكثير خائفون من العوده الى المنازل
الى العوده الى الادوار المرتفعه ايضا
شاهدت بعض السلوكيات التي حدثت بسبب
الزلزال وهي ان يكون يكون متواجدون في
النهار في المنزل لكن في الليل يبتون في
الاماكن العامه والعراء وحتى السيارات وفي
المخيمات خوفا من ان يحدث الزلزال ليلا
وهم نائمون عبد المحسن الحربي لقناتي
العربيه والحدث غازي عنتاب
ونذكر مره اخرى ببيان الدفاع المدني
السوريه الذي قال ان الامكانيات الضعيفه
لديه دفعته الى الانتقال الان من مرحله
البحث والانقاذ الى مرحله انتشال الجثث
بعد ان بات كل المحاولات باستخدام الادوات
المتاحه لديهم بالفشل في محاوله انقاذ حد
يعني او عدد اخر من الناجين تحت الانقاض
بيان محبط بالطبع ولكنه يعكس الصوره في
الشمال السوري
[موسيقى]
ونبقى معكم بالطبع في تغطيه تداعيات هذا
الزلزال ولكن نتوقف الان امام بعض الاخبار
الخاصه بملفات اخرى
اعلن جون كيربي الناطق باسم مجلس الامن
القومي في البيت الابيض ان طائره مقاتله
امريكيه اسقطت هدفا فوق الاسكا في الساعه
الماضيه باوامر مباشره من الرئيس بايدن
واوضح كيربي ان هذا الجسم الذي قال انه
بحجم سياره صغيره شكل تهديدا لامن الملاحه
الجويه
الرئيس دائما يتصرف بالطريقه التي تهدف
الى حمايه مصالح الامريكيين والامن القومي
الاسبوع الماضي تحدثنا عن هدف تم اسقاطه
بنجاح بعد ان حلق فوق الاجواء الامريكيه
واليوم ايضا نتحدث عن هدف لا نعرف تفاصيله
لكنه كان يمثل تهديدا محتملا لسلامه
الطيران المدني بالنظر الى الارتفاع الذي
كان يحلق عليه
وجه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو بتعزيز قوات الامن في منطقه القدس
على خلفيه وقوع هجوم بالدهس اليوم واصفر
هذا الهجوم عن سقوط قتيلين واصابه سبعه
مستوطنين بعضهم دخل المراحل الخطيره كما
وجهنا ايضا بالتحرك الفوري لاغلاق منزل
منفذ العمليه وهدمه بالاضافه الى القاء
القبض على الاشخاص ذو الصله بالمهاجم
هذا وامر وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
بنغفير بعمليه امنيه واسعه في القدس
الشرقيه بعد مقتل اسرائيليين اثنين في
عمليه دهس اليوم الجمعه ونقل تلفزيون اي
24 نيوز الاسرائيلي عن بنجاثور قوله في
بيان ان العمليه ستبدا الاحد وتهدف الى
الوصول الى منازل منافذ الهجمات بهدف
وقفهم قبل تنفيذها وكانت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه اعلنت في وقت سابق مقتل شخصين
واصابه خمسه اخرين في عمليه دهس بسياره
قربه مستوطنه رامون بالقص المحتله
اصدرت وزاره الاستخبارات والحرس الثوري
الايراني بيانا يفيد باعتقال السلطات
لمنفذ هجوم اصفهان بطائرات المسيره وذلك
وفقا لوكاله انباء تسنيم الايرانيه والتي
افادت ايضا بان السلطات تعرفت على اشخاص
قلت انهم تابعين لاسرائيل في الهجوم
بطائرات المسيره على احد المراكز الصناعيه
الخاصه بالصواريخ في اصفهان
هذا وشهدت مدينه زاهدان عاصمه بروجستان في
ايران احتجاجات كبيره اليوم عقب صلاه
الجمعه وطلب المتظاهرون باطلاق سراح
السجناء السياسيين في ايران واسقاط النظام
الايراني اقل امام اهل السنه في ايران
مولوي عبد الحميد ان كافه الشعب الايراني
يريدون التمتع بحقوق متساويه دون تمييز
لاحد مؤكدا ان الشعب الايراني انتفض
لادراكه ان المشكله لا يمكن حلها
ابلغت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاترين
كولونا نظيرها الامريكيه ضروره وجود رد
دولي اقوى على التهديد الذي يشكله برنامج
الصواريخ الباليستيه الايراني الوزيران
طلب طهران بضروره التعاون الكامل مع
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه والوفاء
بالتزاماتها النوويه
اعلنت الخارجيه الروسيه ان نشر الصواريخ
الامريكيه التي تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت في
اليابان يؤثر على الامن والاستقرار
الاستراتيجي في العالم وقالت الناطقه باسم
الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زخرفه ان روسيا
ستراقب عن كتب اي استعدادات لتنفيذ خطه
واشنطن مؤكده ان تنفيذها سيعني تغييرا في
الامن الاقليمي وكانت تقارير اعلاميه ذكرت
ان الولايات المتحده اقترحت نشره صواريخ
متوسطه المدى في اليابان كجزء من خطه
لتعزيز الدفاعات ضد الصين على طول بحر
الصين الشرقي والجنوبي
ومع بدايه الساعه الاولى في اليوم السادس
لكارثه الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال
سوريا نبقى معكم في هذه التغطيه على شاشه
العربيه والزميل صهيب يستمر معكم في هذه
الساعه القادمه